We detected a highly sophisticated and targeted attack on our corporate infrastructure.
I didn't used to think that a foreign military would come after us,...
...and now they obviously are.
This was something that we'd never seen before.
A new kind of problem.
It's not just country versus country.
All of us are somewhat on the front lines.
It's their job 24/7 to try to break into places like Google.
Hope is not a strategy.
You need a team of professionals with exactly the right knowledge and expertise.
That's mildly ominous.
To do the kind of work we do, you need to cherry-pick the best of the best.
I might qualify it by saying I'm an ethical hacker,...
...but yes, let's say I'm a hacker.
Definitely consider myself a hacker.
Hacker.
I wear mostly hoodies for some reason.
This is very serious.
The attacker is after something and you want to find out what they're after.
The attack happened over Christmas.
Santa may arrive late this year.
Someone is always rattling your doorknob to see if it's unlocked.
We're constantly testing our products.
Car companies crash their cars to make sure they're safe.
So do we.
So much more is at stake now.
Human rights.
Privacy.
Professional life.
Personal life.
The entire ecosystem around an election.
It's not just securing Google, it's securing the internet.
I'm in this battle because I believe we can win.
Hunt them down,...
...contain them...
...and then boot them out.
Burn it down.
If any attackers try to get in, I want them to have a very bad day.